you remember van halen remember van
halen back in the days the group
big kids 70s 80s 90s today i want to
talk to you about what van halen can
teach
every single entrepreneur about success
i'm patrick betty a host of
valuetainment weekly and today i want to
talk about van halen and something
they did that was so incredible that
every single entrepreneur can learn from
because so many times you wonder 95
of entrepreneurs they don't make it why
don't they what's the reason for it
it's not only because oh it just didn't
work out there are many many reasons for
where you can find
why that took place so van halen back in
the days
they were a rock band so when these guys
would go and perform in the
boston gardens or the toronto leaves
you know the toronto maple leafs garden
or or it was chicago garden wherever it
was
the the av equipment wasn't prepared to
have a rock band like van
halen they would come and there was a
lot of different things if he didn't do
it right it wasn't safe for
the attendees people could get hurt
there was a lot of different things to
it
and they had to protect themselves so
they had a clause and here's what the
clause was
when when they got a promoter to come
and promote them and get all these
different setups everywhere right
the promoter would have to sign a
contract
with dozens of stipulations they had
writers is what they called it
on the contract that van halen had
if you don't go through these dozens of
things that we have on the checklist
we don't pay you at the end of the show
and so the promoter knew if i get you in
the gardens if i do this if i do this
if i don't follow these dozens you're
not going to get paid at the end of the
show
so a lot of people used to say you know
david lee rod he's a weird guy anyways
all these stories about him going in his
man cave turn the lights off and
be there by himself for days to come up
with music he is a weird guy he is this
he is that
he actually was a very very brilliant
mind the whole group was a brilliant
group and here's what they did
one of the writers they had in the
contract to the promoter
they had things from what specific type
of toilet paper they wanted on and now
90 of the writers 80 of writers were
about how to make it safer for everybody
else
but a couple of them were things that
people would say who cares about having
this
one of them was we want m ms
in backstage but in details
it says but there can be no brown
m m's in there at all none
and if you don't read this line we will
not
pay you and the promoter would sign it
so they would come to perform in chicago
gardens or they would come to perform
anywhere
what would happen they would go through
everything first thing that we checked
is go in the back
in the back stage and they would see the
m ms i would look for brown m ms nope
there's brown m m's we're not paying
them
because they're not prepared then they
would have to go and check everything to
make sure it was safe for people to
attend a rock concert
now you may say give me a break that's
just ridiculous you know what i do say
today
i say pay attention to details so many
times
you know businesses you're running a
business you're doing this you're doing
that and
you're doing a lot of things right
you're not paying attention to your
expenses you're not paying attention to
uh uh the details of an operation you're
not paying attention to
certain numbers you're supposed to track
you're not paying attention to certain
paperwork you're supposed to submit
the proper way you're not paying
attention to certain person that's not
doing the right things the proper way
that could potentially hurt your company
you're not paying attention to the
details and eventually it ends up
backfiring on you
and it ends up hurting you if you don't
pay attention to those specific details
so van halen and your m
m story what a great story i would tell
you to
inspect your business as an entrepreneur
and ask yourself
what areas of my business details
am i not paying attention to that are
hurting my business
and if you're not gonna do it you gotta
hire somebody
to do that part and their job
specifically is to do what
to pay attention to those details so it
doesn't hurt you long term and it
protects
you long term and gives you the highest
chance of succeeding
as an entrepreneur that's my message to
the weekend please be sure to subscribe
to this channel
and comment at the bottom
you